[Music]
a lot of case work that's a big part of
it but as i say that's also one of the
nicest parts of it first thing when i
get up i always check my emails to see
what emails i've had in um during the
evening because actually i think
someone's doing even if you get most
your emails from constituents in because
obviously they're um normally at home
then and they have the time to email you
then i think all councils are different
and it
all councils put different things into
it and some you know some got different
priorities obviously if you've got a
cabinet post and that's completely
different you've got a heavy workload
it's normally just a case of looking at
the diary seeing what meetings have come
up so normally i'd say
every day i'll have one or two meetings
during the day and then
probably a meeting every week in the
evening
we've just been doing the coastal waste
review working party which again you
know that's a very important thing for
the whole of planet so it's been really
interesting being out there um if you're
seen um which i i'm often over in palm
bay it is however much you put into it
really if you want to read around the
subject you know if you want to
get out of your way to help people
you know organizations
yeah it's however much you want to put
into it really if you make time for
anybody who wants to talk to you not
just in your own area
but in the whole of planet then
i don't think you can go far wrong
[Music]